Cris Collinsworth II former three-time
Pro Bowl wide receiver is that right
Chris three-time Pro Bowl wide receiver
with the Bengals that's right a two-time
alternate two-time All Right career
rushing yards for Chris Collinsworth
Paulie I have seven carries for negative
15 yards back my passing records they're
not so good either I got to throw two
passes but one of them hit my roommate
Steve Crider right in the hands in the
end zone but should have been the
game-winning touchdown so instead of
over two with a zero quarterback rating
I should have been one for two one
touchdown and it was a bomb it was a big
shot did you have an interception in
your career yeah I did but it was on
national television so I got a lot of
attention so you were one of the two-way
stars when we talked about the great
two-way stars you you all know you threw
one my bad Chris I'm sorry
so you've you threw an interception I
thought you may have gotten an
interception chris has got the game on
Saturday night it's the Vikings and the
Packers as Brett Hundley is gonna get
the start did you see any scenario where
the that Rodgers would have played in
this game after they were eliminated but
was there any reason why you would have
Rodgers playing this game
I don't think so you know when we were
talking about it before we were all
saying boy I hope he doesn't get hurt in
the Carolina game so he's going to play
but the more you thought about it the
more you knew that if they weren't in
contention which they weren't by the end
of it
like why in the world would you put them
out there so just the whole thing things
are a little crazy to begin with and and
you know Hundley did okay he played a
good game against Pittsburgh and you
know you really do him a chance to win
that football game but against this
defense and this is the defense that got
him hard to begin with Aaron Rodgers so
you know I don't know why you would do
it the Patriots don't invite controversy
they don't create it I mean there is
controversy there's criticism but now
they've created something or have they
with Tom Brady's physical guru health
guru here where they've banned him from
the sidelines and team planes at this
point in the season Chris how surprising
are you that this is a story and I don't
know how big a story but it's a big
story enough for me Oh nationally well I
mean it is a little bit of a story
because so much of Brady's I don't know
future maybe relies on this-tv 12 and
and you know he really he believes that
you know he really believes that what
he's doing as far as lifting weights and
training is the reason that he's able to
have such a long career the reason he's
been so successful and if nothing else
from a pure marketing standpoint it's
not great for TV 12 right so I
understand why it's a little bit of a
story but I also understand the way
those teams work and and team doctors in
general had the final say over
everything that goes on and if there was
ever conflict between the team doctors
and whatever Tom's guy felt and maybe
that was creating a bit of a stir in the
locker room I don't know I'm just I'm
just guessing and speculating here but
yeah I would imagine it's a little
uncomfortable yeah just the timing of it
is is strange that you know now it comes
out and why with two games left and here
you are their favorites to repeat a
Super Bowl champ so and you know just
with Belichick not wanting to
acknowledge it Brady doesn't want to
acknowledge it but you know it's sort of
simmering there somewhere in the
Gillette Stadium yeah well they're not
really good at openly discussing any
issues in New England so it leads to a
lot of speculation and and I have a
feeling that the answer is going to be
you know nothing's going to get in the
way of us winning another Super Bowl
together and you know sometimes there
may be hard feelings or disagreements or
whatever but I think that's been the
singular most impressive part of what's
happened in New England that they can
kind of plow through any of these these
side items and and find a way to play
their best football but they are good at
compartmentalizing I think the Steelers
have let this linger with how that game
ended and you know there's
finger-pointing and who called the spike
and non spike Antonio Brown is hurt
you know the drop pass like the the
Patriots move on the Steelers why are
they holding onto this and still
answering questions on this instead of
just saying look we're on to our next
game you know what we're not looking
back well it's one of the issues I think
when you hold press conferences
throughout the course of the week you
know I mean when you get you get
Roethlisberger's reaction to it right
after the game you're going to get the
head coach's reaction to it in another
press area right after the game you're
going to get the offensive coordinator
Todd Haley's reaction to it on Wednesday
after he's probably been beat up in the
press for not doing whatever it was that
you know the other guys have talked
about or the other rumors have been but
honestly if you've been around that
Pittsburgh organization I mean there is
a little bit of that sort of
in any way there there's a bit of you
know who's calling the plays certain
people are calling to plays and the
no-huddle is it coming from heylia is it
coming from you know there's always
philosophical differences on how the
game should it be more of lay beyond
bell should it be more of no huddle
should it be more of Ben Roethlisberger
should be more of a Antonio Brown I mean
there are a lot of stars that have to
get fed and in Pittsburgh and so I think
it's you know I I do think there are
disagreements on how a calling and play
selection and play operation come down
the road there but obviously their
success has been the overriding factor
and you know there are a lot of there
are a lot of egos in play not just in
Pittsburgh but in New England and around
the National Football League and that's
what makes you know the great head
coaches great head coaches I mean the
ability of Bill Belichick and Mike
Tomlin to control some of those
discussions and to keep them in-house
and when they do percolate over put the
lid back on the pot you know that's a
big part of being a head coach and
that's why those two organizations have
worked so well with those two head
coaches he's Chris Collinsworth he's got
the Vikings Packers Saturday night on
NBC the Sunday Night Football this
weekend on Saturday night how invested
would you be with the Rams moving into
the postseason I don't know what's not
to like about the Rams they've got a
star running back they have quality
receivers they have a very good
offensive line they have people that can
rush the passer
I have Aaron Donald who's playing as
well as anybody in football right now so
you know I mean this is this is this a
good football team the biggest problem
they have is they haven't been on
national television very much so I don't
think very many people know that much
about it I remember we did a Thursday
night game out there early in the season
against San Francisco and we were all
employed as a great game came right down
to the wire the rams pulled it out and
we were leaving the stadium thinking boy
this is a cute game between two bags
lisa was close maybe or worked out you
know yeah and then yeah the other one
that I like is this guy Lance Kendricks
he's playing for the Green Bay Packers
now who was a tight end on the Rams for
what five years something like that
and he left in part because they wanted
to have a chance to go to the playoffs
so he comes to Green Bay they're out of
the playoffs and the Rams are in the
playoffs so and just goes the show of
this league who knows you having played
the position of wide receiver was there
ever a point in your pro career where
you wondered what a catch was or wasn't
never never
yeah I know where you're going with this
one and I have a feeling we're gonna be
talking about this on the pregame show
this weekend but I I don't like words
had it at all I think that in the same
way a runner if he has controlled the
football and breaks the plane of the
goal line got a touchdown I don't
understand why a receiver who has
control the football albeit going to the
ground as part of the process of the
catch or whatever the heck you want to
say but the whole reason why that rule
was put in place was that they didn't
want to create unnecessary fumbles in
other words they would rather have an
incomplete pass then something ruled a
turnover because the guy didn't control
the football in my estimation the goal
line and the out-of-bounds lines are two
distinct areas of the football field so
if you have controlled the football and
you have two feet that have touched and
you break the plane of the goal line or
you go out of bounds
I don't really care what happens when
you hit the ground
out-of-bounds or in the end zone yeah
because if it's a touchdown on a run it
should be a touchdown on a pass and if
it's out of bounds then it doesn't
matter well you're not fumbling the ball
if you're out of bounds so I think that
in this this era in this league where
everything is create
to help improve offensive football I
mean let's face it it is what holding is
now unbelievable what's allowed and
holding it you used to be if you
remember like the old electric football
stuff the guys had to have their hands
together at their chest and their wings
out to try and block somebody you could
take their hands in their chest now I
swear to you can wrap your arms around
the outside of anybody who rushes the
passer and that's not a foul so if we've
evolved to try and open up the offense
with offensive holding like that why the
heck are we taking touchdowns and
game-winning plays off the board over
this rule that I still don't know how I
created about taking the ball all the
way to the ground
I've never liked it I think it makes it
too hard to officiate I think it brings
slow motion instant replay way too much
into effect if a guy has controlled the
ball and goes out of bounds or breaks
the play in the goal line that should be
it I'll leave you with this Derek Carr
said he would have made the same play
that he did when he fumbled the ball out
of the end zone against the Dallas
Cowboys is there a way because I you're
making an athletic move and can I can I
have the ball at the 1 or if you fumble
it through the end zone while trying to
make I mean we love these pylon moments
where you're trying to score a touchdown
and trying to get it over the pylon what
if we brought it back to the 20-yard
line and the offensive team was still
able to have possession of the ball why
should you lose the ball if it goes
through the end zone yeah I'm gonna go
on the other side of that one I think
that is I think that is control of the
football in the field of play and if you
lose control of the football in the
field of play you're responsible for it
now the interesting part of that is that
if you fumble the ball forward and out
of bounds you don't get the benefit of
that in the last two minutes the ball
would come back to the spot right so you
know there's an argument and there was a
little debate even within our truck that
night as to whether or not how is that
going to get ruled does it come back to
the spot or is it is it a touch back but
I think that controlling the football in
the field
play is something you're responsible for
and there are a lot of teams that coach
it to where you are not on you're not
allowed to reach that ball out to the
end zone and that pylon play because the
price that you pay for possibly losing
it is just simply too great you're a
buzzkill man I know I killed Alan I
helped out the 100k all right all right
we'll save it for Saturday night
thank you Chris we appreciate your time
as always yeah buddy happy holidays
thanks you too that's Chris Collinsworth
Sunday Night Football and Saturday night
Vikings and the Packers for more Dan
Patrick show to the audience Channel 239
on DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]